my name's Tim Hetherington I'm Sebastian
Junger our film is called restrepo
cold spinning all day and we come from
the east coast with the snow and we're
hoping for a kind of nice warm Hollywood
reception but at least the people of
your mom is great to be here it's great
to be nominated with the lighter
years
by the first war than i covered was
nineteen ninety-three in Bosnia this is
our first film and but I we did we put
in 10,000 hours you might know except
now yeah i know i did we've been word
for this for a long time you know i hope
you've translated into objects are
territorial debut
is it all three
Ben
you know I don't know what criteria they
use in judging the films I mean we're
very very lucky to be here a lot of film
good films are here you know so I mean
what we did was we made a film we have a
film crew we made a film with the
equipment that we could carry our back
in combat our primary concern was not
getting into into this festival into
this competition or the Academy was a
nugget killed that was our first concern
making this build to survive it
and but you know there's all different
ways of taking risks as a filmmaker and
not necessarily with your life but in
other ways and I think all the film's is
here are really
you know we made an independent film we
financed it ourselves we showed
ourselves and we basically put it out
there with National Geographic but the
distribution of its low key and you know
of course is huge whistle well there's a
recession on the moment and i'm sure
that facing the same kind of dip boys i
would say that you know the combination
now of Netflix and Twitter means that
film distribution changing and that's a
good thing and it can make new tissue
distribution models were all kind of
more applicable I think it's going to
change the better
all the projects here today we could
switch to know we could I don't know a
better answer that one yeah I don't know
I no idea yeah that's a tough one we're
so focused on this it's like it's
actually very hard to ya again you know
I was wearing my flight jacket
Afghanistan let's go through wired today
so if I put my head above the parapet
I'm chemic read what might happen